А ми маємо сказати що корупція під час
воєнного стану - це мародерство - це
життя це смерть це те що є категорично
неприпустима І взагалі за корупцію від
час воєнного стану Покарання має бути
пожиттєве і нічого іншого На жаль ми
бачимо як день за днем стає все більше
інформації з'являється саме про корупцію
і підозрюю про корупцію під час війни та
ще й що найбільш ганебно в міністерстві
оборони України що є просто колосальним
викликом і є колосальною проблемою і
ганьбою і те з чим ми маємо поборотися
негайно тому що за кожною такою справою
це є життя наших воїнів життя наших
героїв це є наша перемога і чи буде ця
перемога тому що кожна такий скандал він
ста питання підтримку України він
ставить під питання Віру українців в
своє в свою державу і це треба негайно
припиняти Я буквально нагадаю декілька
речей за останній час
корупційний скандал про закупівлю
продуктів харчування за якісь
власнословні кошти яйця по 17 грн вже
стали мемом і нам розповідав міністр
оборони резніков що нічого цього нема це
все неправда далі вивели що все є все
правда купляли да внесли зміни А так
яйця по 17 грн Ну за це знаєте яке
покарання Ну треба відривати те що по 17
грн хотіли купляти купляли за державний
кошт називалися в такий момент коли
кожен українець кожну копійку несе для
того щоб допомогти збройним силам
України Гончаренко центр як є краплиною
в океані українського волонтерства ми за
цей час все що можемо віддаємо говорять
діти до нас безкоштовно навчатися
англійській мові по всіх містах України
і приносять там гривню 5-10 на ЗСУ на
дрова на антидрон на всю підтримку а в
цей час хтось
просто грабує Міністерство оборони
грабує державні кошти друзі це є
неприпустимо на жаль далі це не
зупинилося далі скандал про турнікети це
взагалі це за межею всього купляти
китайські турнікети в аптечке для наших
військових які не рятують життя кожен
такий турнікет куплений це можливо життя
чи здоров'я к наших героїв Ну як це може
бути Ну в принципі Як таке могло статися
Ми знов чуємо якісь незрозумілі
пояснення і знову це все йде тут питання
до командування медичних сил і це наше
Міністерство оборони далі останні
скандал
закупівлю і зимового одягу коли зимовий
одяг куплявся в Три дороги коли це
заходила з Туреччини від якоїсь компанії
там взагалі якоїсь плетньов власник який
в квітні 22-го року виїхав з України в
квітні а в серпні створює він фірму з
якою Міністерство оборони заключає угоди
і починає туди відправляти кошти Ну це ж
ну просто ну така схема на якогось зі
председателя який навіть ще й не в
Україні знаходиться і далі ці заходять
куртки які коштують одну ціну тут же
міняється інвойс схема ламаної інвойтс в
три рази більше і це все сплачується
коштом платників податків України і знов
Міністерство оборони сказали нє-нє Це
все брехня виявляється все правда
сьогодні було засідання антикорупційного
комітету все підтверджується всі дані
підтверджуються
міністр оборони резніков навіть не
прийшов не прийшов на засідання
парламенту Ну поясніть мені Як таке може
бути дрезніков
скільки це буде тривати Чому він не
виходив в мене багато питань де година
запитань до уряду Я хочу спитати
різнікова скільки буде тривати корупція
в Міноборони
стільки це буде тривати Якщо нам кажуть
що він до цього не причетний то або ну
тобто або він причетний до цього Або
якщо він не причетний то що це за
менеджер що це за керівник при якому
таке відбувається нам треба ставити з
цим крапку інакше ми програємо інакше ми
втратимо все корупція під час війни
вбиває